hey catherine evans hey
um i cannot tell you how much fun i had
watching this movie i mean definitely
the horror version of freaky friday
so funny the scenes were so gory i just
loved it so catherine i want to know on
a scale of one to ten
how good was vince at embodying you he
was too good at it it's a little
embarrassing how good he is at
acting like me you know i thought like i
would try to act like vince right but
the truth is
i just see myself in everything he was
doing i was like that's really how i run
isn't it that is what i do with my hair
isn't it
so all these things when i was watching
the movie the first time i was like
i need to stop touching my hair like i
need to stop
doing that because i do it is true so he
killed it
he's very good at it that's amazing i
was going to ask you vince about the
running every time you ran i was
giggling
uh was that kind of like the number one
thing you wanted to get down when it
came to embodying you know a 17 year old
girl important part of playing millie
her run
the run you know catherine and me really
built these characters out together
you know so we kind of found these
physicalities together and one other
thing i think was cather's idea was to
kind of keep our hands high when we ran
and just find things like that she was
so much fun to
to to work on these characters with you
know a lot of the physicality
where there's things that we would kind
of collaborate on and and work together
to
to do so i think both those characters
were kind of just more
specific characters than either one of
us perfectly
although the run might be closer to my
own run probably than i would be willing
to admit
[Laughter]
thank you thank you yeah that felt
honest
so you talked about the fun elements of
it vince what was the most challenging
part of this character for you
you know i think once we were in it we
were in it i think the build up to it
the preparation was a lot because you
just had to
have both kind of very different
characters to be ready to dive into
one's kind of lovely and vulnerable and
the other is really cold and mean
so um i think we had a lot of fun in
rehearsal
and we had a great time coming up with
stuff and talking about things so it
made the day
actually filming was easy but the prep
time was quite a bit
yeah um catherine you freaked me out in
this you
played such a good serial killer thank
you very much i'm very proud of that
accomplishment you should be i mean it's
nothing like me in real life so
i'm way more like millie you know so
thank you
is this true totally katherine's the
funniest nicest easiest person so
she i remember getting called it to the
set like after she had filmed a scene
yeah so she'd be in the butcher's like
wardrobe covered in blood
but not playing the bushes so it'd be
catherine she'd be so nice she'd like
hey guys i wanted you guys to see you
and meanwhile she looks like just like
she came out of like some slaughter fest
yeah that's awesome um catherine would
you have liked blood on you just all the
time
at the end of your scenes basically once
you reach a certain kill point you're
covered in blood
and then they've got to continually put
the same amount of blood on you every
day
so you know i got kind of used to it and
i kind of enjoyed the
extra intimidation factor that i was
carrying around you know it helps with
the outfit the leather jacket helps and
obviously
wielding a chainsaw not much there's not
many other accessories that can have
that kind of impact on people
love it intimidation on set the whole
time love it um
vince you've recently talked about how
you guys are in serious talks for a
wedding crasher's sequel so i have to
ask
have you reached out to our canadian
girl rachel mcadams yet
yeah you know um we just started talking
about
um kind of an idea i think there's the
director obviously david i think has
ideas uh he's gonna include the cast but
there hasn't been anything
you know specifically overly formalized
with everyone yet it's just sort of an
idea that we kind of thought was a fun
way in
yeah and katherine i saw you do this are
you excited i'm so excited i just you
know want to be in it but it's fine
mcadams is terrific rachel's rachel's
great so you'd have to have her
of course well thanks so much guys had
such a blast watching you both in this
thanks for chatting have a great morning